hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over
vichyanan's greatest chess game he ever
played
also happens to be one of my favorite
games of all time hopefully you enjoy it
as much as i do this game took place in
2013
at a tata steel tournament one of the
top tournaments
every year and his opponent was levon
oroni and playing the white pieces now
vishyanan was the world champion
at this time so he was at the top of his
game and lavonna ronian was the number
three rated player in the world
so we have two heavyweights it's always
nice when your best game you show up
against
the top players in the world so it
starts out with longer room playing
d4 and then after d5 we get into the
queen's game bit with c4
queen's game decline with c6 then after
knight f3
knight f6 knight to c3 and then pawn
to e6 so this is getting into the
semislav line
then white has a couple options but
about half the time you'll see white
just play e3
opening up for the light square bishop
to get involved into the game getting
ready to castle on the king side
sacrificing the dark square bishop for
getting
involved into the game right away knight
to d7 the main line here
bishop to d3 and usually black's going
to see this
and start to chip away here on the queen
side so
pawn takes on c4 and black gives up
this pawn in the center of the board so
for rapid development on
the queen side as well as forcing this
bishop to move
a few places this bishop came here to d3
then it came here to c4 and black's
going to kick it away here with
pawn to b5 bishop's force to come back
here to d3 and this is the natural
square for the bishop on d3
uh it allows for the pawn to push
forward here at e4
at some point the knight to come here at
e4 if they want to from black standpoint
uh wants to push this pawn forward here
to c5
uh this is a semi-open file it's a
backward pawn here on c6 a little
awkward
eventually white can bring his rook here
to c1 and start to attack
this backward pawn here also wants to
bring his bishop here to b7
attack this long diagonal so if he can
push forward with his pawn there that's
that's definitely gonna be his plan
that he's looking for uh and then we see
bishop to uh d6
vishyanan had a few options uh could
have played bishop to b7 right away
could have also played a6
defending this square here on b5 so he
could push forward with
c5 ops for the line to continue in the
center of the board and control this
also if he wants to at some point uh can
push forward here on e5 but does want to
protect this square here on e5
so brings his bishop here to d6 now
levon aronian is going to continue
with castling on the king side castling
on the king side here for
black and then queen to c2
now vishnam brings his bishop to b7
and then a three from white and this is
preparing for the pawn to come here to
b4 wants to stop any sort of push that
vichyanan has here to
the c5 square and then rook to c8 and
this is a nifty move from vishyanan as
he prepares
for attacks later in the game there's a
pawn and a knight here on the c file but
putting this rook on the same file as
the queen
is always good because he expects this
pawn to come off at some point and this
knight's gonna be pinned down putting a
lot of pressure on
white side then we have knights of g5
and you can start to see what white's
plan is this knight this bishop and
queen are all eyeing the square here on
h7
and black doesn't have enough defenders
just has the knight here on
f6 but that's it so vishyanan says
okay i don't really care too much i'm
going to continue with my own attack and
play
c5 wants to open up for all these pieces
to eye
on the king side of the board for levon
rhony and you can see this bishop here
on a d6 controlling the dark square
diagonal
this bishop here on b7 is now activated
control this light square diagonal
and so after white plays knight takes
here on h7 the bishonon does not care at
all
giving up his rook on f8 if white wants
it and plays knight to
g4
white can start to see all the threats
that black has
in plays f4 this does stop the immediate
threat of bishop taking here on h2 or
the night taking here on h2
and then we see the pawn take on d4 and
after the pawn takes
then we start to see the brilliance of
vishyanan with one of his first
miraculous moves that he finds and the
first one is bishop here to
c5 and this is so difficult for white to
deal with because
you have this opponent the world
champion playing this against you you're
the number three player in the world and
you're
trying to figure out what is going on he
has so many attacks he's not just
going to play bishop here to c5 unless
he has a really strong reason to
if you take here he's going to recapture
with his knight on
c5 this opens up for the queen to come
here to d4
so if you know the bishop takes then the
queen's gonna come up here to d4
uh and then all of a sudden knight to e4
gets involved into the game and there's
so many threats that we have here from
black standpoint
some other mates definitely an option
here if you don't take with your bishop
maybe if you just try to gobble up
material
but black doesn't really care about this
rook here on f8 he can swing in with
queen 2
d4 king 2 h1
knight takes here pawn h3 trying to kick
this knight away that's fine check here
on
f2 and you can start to see that black
has a very dominant position
after the king takes here on f8 you can
really see this rook on
a1 is not doing anything this bishop
here on c1 is blocked by this pawn
and there's just so many threats that
black has on the board should be a
pretty easy
game for vichyanan so in this after the
bishop came to
c5 we see levon aronian bring his bishop
back here to e2
now if you thought the move to bishop to
c5 was a good one the next one
is even better feel free to stop the
video see if you can find black's move
here
and vishyanan found the move knight to
e5
which doesn't even look like a move that
a mere mortal is going
to make if you like this move feel free
to hit the like button on the video
definitely supports the channel and if
ishinon ever watches this video which i
hope he does
he will know that you were impressed by
his move here on knight to e5
but it's just so difficult for white to
deal with you can start to see all the
threats if the pawn takes here on e5
this is gonna end in mates queen takes
on d4
check you could come bishop to e3 to
stop the threat but it's just stopping
it for one move
queen takes on e3 king to h1
after queen two g1 can't take it with
this keen because the bishop here on
c5 rook takes here and then you have
smothered mate with
knight two f2 if we come back maybe the
pawn doesn't take here on
e5 but the pawn takes here on a c5
well this is still going to be made
queen take or queen 2 d4
check bishop here to e3 you can have
some in between moves
after queen 2 h3 the pawn can't take
it's being pinned down by
this bishop here on b7 but maybe
bishop takes here on g4 knight takes
here
knight to f6 check just delaying the
inevitable pawn takes here on f6
queen down here just trying to stop mate
as much as you can
but after king takes on h7 uh then
maybe c6 uh this is stopping uh the the
pin here
but then it's still going to be mate
with queen takes on h2
so at the end of the day you can see
none of those are
going to work and that's part of the the
reason that of the genius of the move to
knight to
e5 and how vishyanan's calculating all
that and saying yeah that is the move
that i want to do how it even shows up
on his radar
is amazing but after knight to e5 we
have the move bishop
takes here on g4 and then bishop takes
here on
d4 could have taken the bishop right
away but does have the check here on
d4 taking that material so after bishop
takes on
d4 check king to h1 and then knight to
g4
you can start to see that white's
position is falling apart here black has
so many threats tonight here on
g4 attacking all the king side the board
the bishop here on d4
centralized attacking the square here on
a g1 bishop here on b7
sometimes you almost forget about it but
it's definitely pinning down this pawn
on
g2 and stopping a lot of the squares
that white would want to come to on the
king side of the board
and then you start to look at his pieces
rook here on a1 is not doing too much
bishop here on c1 was never able to
activate that one of the things that
white has to worry about in the semislav
after they play that e3 move early on is
getting that dark square bishop involved
into the game it is not
then you start to look at how is white
really going to continue decides to go
and gobble up material here on
f8 next move could come down with queen
to h7 here and then bishon on plays the
move
f5 and while he's playing moves
throughout that are just brilliant i
think
f5 just shows you how
many variations he was looking at and
because f5
puts a stop to all the threats that
white was thinking about
if he takes with his king here on f8
then the queen can just come down to h7
eventually check but really this queen
is now
controlling this h file vishyanam wants
to bring his queen to h4 but it wouldn't
be able to do that
the move with pawn to f5 stops that
completely
if he takes with his queen well now the
queen's out of the picture that would be
good for white he plays
queen 2 e2 threatening this pawn here on
b5 centralizing that queen a little bit
more maybe now pawn to f5 but doesn't
matter knight
two b5 now attacking this bishop here on
d4 so uh instead of taking
that knight just said don't have to
worry about that i'm gonna go ahead and
play
pawn two f5 now the knight comes to g6
can't take here on e6 because queen two
h4 and this is going to be
mate there's no way for white to stop
this
you could see pawn to h3 but queen takes
here on h3 this is mate because again
this pawn is pinned down by the bishop
here on a b7
cannot take this queen so uh does need
to
bring his knight to g6
this does stop the queen from coming to
h4
right away but now the queen just comes
up to f6
both controlling the square here on d4
with his bishop
as well as attacking the knight here on
g6
right now trying to relieve some of the
pressure plays h3
doesn't even matter says yeah go ahead
and take that that's fine queen takes
here
on uh g6 queen over here to
e2 putting another attacker on of the
knight on
g4 and then we have queen two h5 the
pawn can't take this
knight here on g4 it's being pinned down
by the queen
the queen takes well the pawn just going
to recapture that queen here on
g4 so can't do that there's just no
great squares
that white has decides to bring his
queen back here to d3
adding another defender on the square
here on h3 since the pawn can't
recapture it's being pinned down by this
bishop right here
and then you have another great move by
vishyanan it
just so happens to be the one that ends
the game and that is bishop
to e3 and it doesn't even
look like a move that you would find
here because it
your opponent can just take this right
away but
actually can't when you start to dig
into it and so levona ronian in this
spot
resigned we'll go ahead and look at some
of the variations but after he resigned
asked for vishyanan's autograph to take
a picture with him
he didn't actually but that's at least
what i tell myself and what i tell my
kids at night when we go over chess
bedtime stories but let's take a look at
some of the options here the bishop
takes on
e3 okay well now queen takes on
h3 remember that bishop to e3 was just
blocking this queen on d3 such a
brilliant move here this pawn is still
being pinned down by the bishop
on b7 here king to g1
and then it's going to be checkmate now
let's say that
instead of this after the bishop 2 e3
well what if the queen just takes here
well you can probably see the knight
takes here on e3
after the bishop takes queen two h3 this
is not going to be good it's going to be
checkmate as well
now potentially another move would be
knight to e4 this is stopping the bishop
now the bishop can just take here but
now
queen takes on e4 but then you're just
going to lose the queen here
at the end of the day uh you know
black's just going to be up so much
material there's no way
for white to stop this so vishin on just
finding
all the right moves black
and many times you see the greatest
games ever it's someone playing as white
and they just find an aggressive line
and they just continue and continue
vishyanan playing a defense not known to
be the most
aggressive and just finding line after
line of putting white in the most
difficult positions even when white was
attacking on the keen side vishyanan
finding the best moves
congratulations to vishyanan especially
after this last one bishop here to e3
2013 was the last year that vishyanan
was the world champion but but wow he
was
he was phenomenal to watch in this game
specifically uh was fun to analyze and
always fun to go back and watch
hopefully you guys enjoy the video as
much
as i did to cover it again if you
haven't already please hit the like
button show the support of the channel
and for vicionon's
greatest chess game thank you guys so
much for watching and i'll see you in
the next video
you